how scum rasma it's pure pact I'm
excited because the day we're gonna put
wet wet wet wet Wow alright calm down
we're playing for test mode it's a new
game it's out on Kickstarter the
developer was nice enough to send me the
demo to check out I'm very excited this
is gonna be awesome alright so here we
are press f to turn your torch to throw
Flay's oh yeah make it rain pick up the
gun
I ran I actually really enjoy games
where you have a gun now cuz not having
one is is so overused after noticing
some strange luminescence and odd
high-pitched sounds from the abandoned
and soon to be a renovated wing of the
campus I decided to investigate
Professor Dyer wrote that Oh God
calm down Professor Dyer I'm dumb hello
oh god I have no idea what's gonna
happen but I have a broom Oh God
back off back off the evil of the night
she'll taste my broom who the hell would
use a broom as it defends actually I
probably would oh god I don't like this
Yona land like or Die Sato
I think that's Italian a health feeling
better already
badass voice I like that nothing like a
badass man with a badass broom if you
know what I'm saying
oh god this sound what the [ __ ] no no no
no no no no no no I have a broom I have
and I'm not afraid of use it oh god oh
god I don't like this
oh god this sound hello what is this
what's happening oh god what is that
sound
oh god lamb hold me ah
hello bro Oh God Oh God ah what happened
oh my god
I am NOT a fan of that what a hell just
happened I died so fast
Brum Brum you didn't do anything broom I
thought you were a bro yeah damn how did
he find me okay we gotta act quicker
this time Jesus Christ I I breathe like
a frickin werewolf oh no oh no oh no
what's happening
that's a nice fire I'm not gonna stay
around for it to take over my life oh
god oh god oh god alright I'll go in the
portal press control to toggle crouch
you can avoid line creatures Oh broom
broom did you hear that broom broom
broom you're the lamest character ever
broom seriously okay so that they're
blind they have that booty though oh god
okay okay oh god oh god okay okay all
right
ah right into my face ah
what is he doing Oh God I got him I got
him oh god there's more there's more
what is happening what is that what that
[ __ ] I yeah what is how I can't oh my
god this is redonkulous and I'm not even
in McDonald's I am awful at this game I
need to try better bring it on you think
I'm scared I never get scared of any
game in my laughs okay control let's
make sure we are the ones in control oh
this looks different now so it's like a
procedurally generated oh shut up
this [ __ ] atmosphere man I'm I don't
know me
alright let's just take it easy
let's take it really [ __ ] easy mate
hello ah there's one let's not go near
it don't get distracted by the Buddha
pills oh God
okay let's just keep going keep
crouching oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god okay we got
this we got days no problem oh yeah yeah
[ __ ]
Siddhartha and isn't it all right we
have to go back we gotta go back back
back in the sack sack sack
what is the broom for the broom is just
one big [ __ ] you isn't it I swear oh
here we go let's use the broom so we
don't make a note oh god don't look at
him don't talk to him don't Oh God
don't oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god they're blind they're blind I am
blind you are blind we are blind we are
all blind I am blind we are blind what
is that it's not a coin money money
money money I'm rich [ __ ] all right we
got Oh God
let's just let's just deal with him Oh
God he's so ugly
ah got him got him
that was a mate you're dead alright
alright
ah ah run run run run run run run run
[ __ ] get off me cop Oh God
run run run don't look back don't look
stop looking back you more ah ah ah I
picked you crazy
broom broom broom get off make up get up
get up get up get up yeah rhythm you're
not gonna take me
you're never gonna give me a lab you're
never gonna get y'all got a bit rent ah
ah ah ah my heart will go on every night
[ __ ]
I am so bad broom you were amazing
Brum Brum Brum Brum i literally can't
wait a hell are we now let's go upstairs
it's like you use the gun to protect
yourself but it it's literally just like
killing yourself let's just use the
broom for now on and dust those dirty
hose off whoa whoa what I I think if we
found the portal right away mind got
here we go here we go here we go oh
press f2 turn off the flashlight you
will be less detectable okay good thank
you game thank you very much and backing
up backing up backing up backing up cuz
there are blinds and bass I'm going the
hell in here
and I'm like broom broom broom broom
broom Berber broom
Oh God he went through the wall all
right don't panic don't panic
Brum Brum don't panic we'll be fine
oh god we're [ __ ] I've got des toast
dirty hose does Stowe's hurt hijos what
is he doing to that poor table these
people have obviously no consideration
for how to clean that all god oh god oh
god I'm sorry
I do apologise can't you take an apology
Jace's Christ we're never gonna get out
of here live all right where are we
wonderful that is a fat one isn't it oh
[ __ ] I think it I think it knows I'm
there let's take likes take the route
behind the couch the route behind the
couch okay what's that oh Jesus data's
room does that bear do does that dirty
hoe just a dirty hoe dirty hoe does
state hello hello ladies excuse me I
would love to date you but I am occupied
with some things stop walking on each
other what kind of friendship are you
Jesus Dyson damn let me dust you up
that's right I'm the dust master of
disaster
stupid dusty hos god no god what have I
done I murdered them oh god let's get
out of here
Oh Tommy feet done oh you did it now oh
what the [ __ ]
hey it's been great very nice thank you
oh oh I can't I can't
uh-huh ah okay one more try cuz I don't
know how much I can handle of this [ __ ]
like a lush ah for [ __ ] sake
I'm such a [ __ ] I know I know very well
that I'm a pay will say I'm [ __ ]
alright so now we know that broom is
pretty much our best friend Rome broom
you've been telling me that all along
broom no I'm not gonna make out with
your broom broom broom shop we got a
quest to handle and it's a quest for
booty all right I don't spot any booty
to you boom Rome very interesting I
agree they do have great asses broom oh
you mean assets okay sorry
so that's the [ __ ] that's the guy that
keeps snatching up Vic died oven ah do
we get we good
oh all right um I work better than
expected it Nate I have a bad habit of
walking into them I need to stop doing
okay okay
I am so tempted oh no I thought I was
further away I'm sorry let me dust you
off ho you dirty hoe dirty hope dirty
hoe you dirty hole dirty hoe dirty hoe
nailed it okay okay okay okay all right
you know what it's dusty time dusty
Dusty dusty Dusty dusty dirty hoe dirty
dodo do slap that booty no all right we
got this no problem
near much probably immersive with we say
in Sweden that's Spanish
Brum Brum you're racist
Brum Brum no I'm not gonna get off your
car broom God broom okay just shut up
I'm swingin changing the pistol cuz
you're a [ __ ] okay all right it's dusty
time I think we're gonna have to just
we're gonna dust you a girl you're
looking fine better dust you off dare to
dust you up I'm just out okay now I
can't I can't okay I no no no no
no you got it all wrong I am NOT just a
gal but I am NOT Jessica I keep telling
them I'm not why don't they listen Oh
goddamn it so it's kind of like a robe
like a horror game in a sense you go
deeper and deeper and it gets harder and
harder kind of that's pretty cool oh god
oh god oh god come on you dirty host now
god they got me with their red stuff
don't get me with it
Oh God ah I don't know what I smoked but
it's some heavy [ __ ] man what the actual
[ __ ] is happening whoa whoa what No all
right I'm gonna have to end that first
episode there hope you bros enjoy
watching if you did hit that like button
don't forget to check out the game if
you're interested I'll leave a link to
the Kickstarter go and support this
would be awesome to see a full version
of and that's all for me for now thank
you for watching stay awesome